[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be counting down the top 10
strongest fighters in the tournament of
power so far we can only go by what the
fighters have shown up to this point so
of course this list could change in the
coming months and if it does I would be
happy to make an updated list in another
video if you happen to disagree with
anything on this list I encourage you to
give me your thoughts in the comments
you guys know that I read them if you
enjoyed the Dragon Ball super content on
this channel be sure to leave a like to
let me know and if you are new don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you want to support
the channel and get cool anime merch
like your girl calls me senpai and keep
calm an ultra instinct you can check out
our merch store link in the description
and now let's get right into it
at number 10 dis Pole known as the sonic
warrior dispo is one of the strongest
members of the universe 11 pride
troopers his biggest asset is his
incredible speed and this boat is so
fast that even the gods of destruction
like Champa and even desi knows couldn't
detect his movement according to models
the Angels could barely detect them
this boat is so fast that he was able to
stop Goku from using instant
transmission because he attacked Goku
faster than Goku could teleport this
pole so has an exceptional sense of
hearing as a result of his large ears
which allows him to detect opponent's
movements sooner than another fighter
might be able to this bow uses his speed
to be an extremely helpful teammate and
support Gian and the other members of
the Pride troopers during their fights
since the tournament of power is a team
battle strong teamwork skills are an
important asset to have in terms of
hands on battle power this bowl does
prove himself to be a formidable threat
as he is able to put up a good fight and
even get the upper hand at least at
first against both hit and Goku however
this boat doesn't rank higher on this
list because his movements during battle
are predictable and as their fights went
on both his and Goku were able to
predict his movements and defeat him
nevertheless his immense speed and the
ability to hold his own at least for a
while against strong fighters like hit
and Goku definitely earns this bowl a
spot on this list at number nine Android
18 Android 18 also excels at teamwork
and she demonstrates her excellent
teamwork skills while fighting alongside
Krillin and Android 70 and also while
supporting Goku at times when he is low
on stamina again this quality is
extremely important for this type of
tournament another very important factor
for this tournament is stamina because
in the tournament of power fighters are
not just going to go up against a single
opponent and when they defeat them the
battle is over instead because there are
so many teams and warriors fighting in
the tournament you could find yourself
defeating one opponent and then
immediately being attacked by another in
quick succession Android 18 has a
crucial advantage in this sense because
as an Android she has an infinite supply
of energy so she doesn't need to rest or
recharge on top of that Android 18 has
shown a lot during this tournament
eliminating five other fighters herself
and helping to eliminate several more as
part of a team even with an injured leg
she is able to dismantle the universe
two warriors together with Android 17 in
just the fact that she took out rib
Rianne gives Android 18 extra points in
my book she definitely deserves to be on
this list at number 8 Android 17 just
like Android 18 17 has an infinite
supply of energy which is a huge asset
in this type of tournament also like 18
17 is not a great job working as part of
a team and supporting Goku in his time
of need we actually know that Android 17
possesses more power than 18 and this is
confirmed in the dies n shoe official
Dragon Ball guidebook for this reason
Android 17 ranks higher than ant
18 on this list it is important to note
that 17 has also been impressive
throughout the tournament eliminating at
least three fighters himself and helping
to eliminate several others as a result
of his teamwork at number seven
Topol topo is a candidate for the next
god of destruction of universe 11 which
alone should be enough to give us an
idea of how powerful he is
even before the tournament of power we
see that Tocqueville was able to hold
his own against super saiyan blue goku
in the extra battle of the zen
exhibition match although unfortunately
we didn't get to see them go all-out at
that point during the tournament of
power topo does show some impressive
fighting skills but eventually we see
that both he and dispo are powerless
against Goku once he attains the ultra
instinct omen form later on we also see
topo briefly fight Super Saiyan blue
Vegeta but both of them are soon
distracted by the fight between Goku and
kefla so we don't get to see them go
all-out either however we know that tofu
considers vegeta to be the number two
fighter from universe 7 just like he is
the number 2 fighter from universe 11
which confirms that topo is stronger
than this bowl but weaker than jitta i
am definitely looking forward to seeing
topples full power in action sometime in
the future at number 6 vegeta the Prince
of Saiyans Vegeta is considered to be
the second strongest universe 7 fighter
and just like Goku Vegeta trained under
the universe 7 angel wheeze Vegeta is
capable of attaining the super saiyan
blue transformation and up until
recently he has been able to keep up
with Goku in terms of power in
preparation for the tournament Vegeta
trained alone in the hyperbolic time
chamber and he became so strong that he
managed to destroy a part of it just by
powering up although his behavior during
the tournament has been a bit odd at
times like his refusal to contribute
energy to Goku spirit bomb when even
Frieza agreed to help out Vegeta has
been busy as well by my count Vegeta has
eliminated more fighters from the turn
than anyone else with a grand total of
nine so far I also believe that Vegeta
is hiding something some hidden power or
technique that he will reveal in the
future and I talked about why I believe
that in a previous video I will leave a
link to that video in the description if
you want to check it out for this reason
my gut instinct tells me that Vegeta is
stronger than Tocqueville at this point
but in order for Vegeta to rank higher
on this list he first needs to show
himself against the strongest fighters
in the tournament and he hasn't really
done that up to this point at number 5
Frieza even among members of his own
powerful race Frieza is considered a
prodigy with unparalleled power and
potential by attaining the golden Frieza
and true golden Frieza forms he has been
able to keep up and in some cases even
get the upper hand on Super Saiyan blue
goku and vegeta
and an episode 95 freezes able to
overcome cedras energy of destruction
and the Supreme Kai of universe 9 tells
Sidra that Frieza is more of a god of
destruction than him another crucial
advantage that Frieza has which puts him
ahead of Vegeta and many others in my
mind is his great cunning and ability to
strategize as well as his willingness to
do whatever it takes to win Frieza has
shown himself to be a valuable member of
the team time and time again even
helping Goku and Gohan while betraying a
member of his own race frost but more
than that Frieza has shown himself to be
willing to do the dirty work that the
other members of his team are not
willing to do for example Vegeta saves
Kaabah
because as a Saiyan he feels some sort
of compassion for a member of his race
even though Kappa is fighting for a
rival universe earlier in the tournament
Goku allowed Khalif LA and kale to get
away in order to recover so that he
could face off against them again when
they were at full strength Goku and
Vegeta want to prove that they are the
strongest fighters and they are willing
to let their enemies recover or get
stronger because they want to face the
biggest challenge possible but this is
an elimination
tournament and the losing teams will
have their entire universe erased their
friends families everyone they ever knew
gone forever if we look at it from a
practical perspective there is no room
for compassion here if the lives of
everyone you've ever known rests on your
shoulders and on you winning this
tournament everyone who is fighting for
another universe is your enemy
unlike some of the others Frieza is
aware of this and he isn't afraid to do
the dirty work that the Saiyans and
other members of universe 7 refused to
do Frieza knows that in a tournament
like this one there is no room for
compassion toward your rivals and this
is what makes him such an asset to the
universe 17 in fact I made an entire
video about why Frieza might turn out to
be one of the MVPs of the universe 17 in
this tournament link to that video is in
the description
finally Frieza has also been cleverly
conserving his stamina so far in the
tournament and he has been avoiding
going golden for the vast majority of
the time so I definitely think that he
will prove to be one of the strongest
and most useful fighters as we get
closer to the end of the tournament for
this reason Frieza earned his spot at
number five at number four kefla by
using the Patara earrings universe sixes
two female Saiyans kale and cauliflower
combined to become the extremely
powerful warrior kefla the reason that
I'm including kefla here as opposed to
listing Kalin khalifa separately but not
including vegeto is because so far in
the tournament we have seen Kevlar in
action while we haven't seen Vegeta yet
and I am compiling the list based on
what we've actually seen so far needless
to say I think that if vegeto does make
an appearance in the tournament
especially now that Goku is able to
achieve the ultra instinct omen form
Vegeta will be way more powerful than
calf lot no doubt about it
kefla is a fusion of Kali flock who we
know had succeeded in reaching
two percent do in a very short period of
time with kale who has a unique and
insanely powerful Berserker Super Saiyan
power inside her similar to broli in the
Dragon Ball Z movie kefla is capable of
going super saiyan 2 and in this form
she is able to defeat x 20 kaio-ken Goku
Super Saiyan blue which is just insane
but once Goku enters the ultra instinct
Ohman form for the second time he is
able to eliminate her from the
tournament using the sliding kamehameha
also known as the Tony Hawk kamehameha
within the fandom unfortunately we
didn't get a chance to seek a fly co-op
against Jaden to see how she would fare
against him but since she was defeated
by Goku who is yet to master his ultra
instinct Ullman form kefla we'll have to
settle for number 4 on this list at
number 3 hit the legendary assassin hit
is widely considered to be the most
powerful fighter from universe 6 he
demonstrated his spectacular fighting
abilities even before the tournament of
power including during the tournament of
destroyers and during his subsequent
fight with Goku hit has mastered a
technique called time-skip which is both
incredibly rare and difficult to master
this technique allows him to actually
skip time by a fraction of a second and
hit is able to gradually improve the
technique to increase the length of the
skips the nature and rarity of the
time-skip gives hit a major advantage in
battle especially against opponents who
haven't faced them before as a result of
continuously working to improve his time
skin technique hit was able to develop a
supporting technique called Cage of time
which he used against Jaden during the
tournament of power using this technique
hit is able to suspend his opponent in
time and essentially paralyze the
opponent using the cage of time hit is
able to put up a fierce fight even
against the incredibly powerful of
cheatin and for a while it seemed as
though Gina might actually be eliminated
by him
however Jaden ultimately
to overpower and eliminate hit it is
worth noting that Jaden himself says
that the two opponents that pose the
biggest threat to him were Goku and hit
so it is no surprise that hit lands at
the number three spot on our list at
number two
Goku a man who needs no introduction
son Goku also known as Kakarot is
considered to be the strongest fighter
on the universe 17 having recently
achieved the ultra instinct omen form
Goku is now able to use the technique
known as ultra instinct which is a rare
ability that is difficult to master even
for gods of destruction this technique
enables the user to respond to attacks
automatically without thinking with
ultra instinct Goku is able to use
incredible speed to effectively dodge
attacks but we eventually learned that
attacking is more difficult to master
while using ultra instinct since
attacking usually requires thought and
until one learns to attack without
thinking their physical attacks will be
weaker as we saw during the fight
between Goku and kefla nevertheless when
he first achieves this form Goku is the
only fighter that we have seen so far
fighting on par with Jaden
although only briefly because Goku still
hasn't mastered the new ultra instinct
omen form and so he cannot maintain it
for more than a short period of time
Goku is definitely improving quickly in
the second time he transformed into
ultra instinct omen against kefla he
appeared to have made a lot of progress
from the first time but he still has a
long way to go before he masters this
form and we know that while he has been
dodging attacks effectively he still
needs to unlock the offensive potential
of ultra instinct and for this reason
goku lands at number 2 and finally at
number 1 Monica or he would be if he was
fighting in the tournament but instead
at number one we have cheetah cheetah
and the grey is the strongest member of
the universe 11 pride troopers and he is
the fabled mortal who is known to be
stronger than his
universe's god of destruction g10 ski is
so unbelievably massive that it made the
entire world of void shake and even
Frieza referred to Jaden as a monster
after witnessing Jaden's power Jaden can
take out opponents with nothing more
than a glance and according to vados and
shin during his battle with hit
Sheeran's power was shown to transcend
time itself because he somehow managed
to free himself from his cage of time in
addition Jaden demonstrates his
superiority throughout the tournament
thus far defeating Berserker kale with
almost no effort while super saiyan blue
goku was struggling against her Jaden is
so confident in his abilities that he
allowed Goku to charge the spirit bomb
fully without interruption and yet the
attack still couldn't even face Jaden
and he actually managed to send a spirit
bomb back at Goku jiren later
successfully wore down ultra instinct oh
man Goku to the point that Goku could no
longer sustain his new form and after
defeating Goku Gian would later go on to
breakthrough hits cage of time and
eliminate the incredibly powerful hit as
well at this point we are not even sure
how much of his full power Jaden has
revealed he could still be concealing a
lot more and for this reason Gina is
without a doubt the number one strongest
fighter on our list so what do you guys
think do you agree with this list did I
miss anything and what changes would you
make let me know down in the comments
and also let me know what you think is
going to happen as the tournament
progresses who do you think will end up
being the strongest fighter at the end
of the tournament will it be ultra
instinct vegeto after goku and vegeta
used the Patara to fuse or someone else
entirely drop me a line down below if
you want to give me ideas for future
videos that you want to see on this
channel be sure to follow us on twitter
at anime uproar if you enjoy this type
of video be sure to leave a like to let
me know and if you are new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell as always
thank you all so much for watching
huge thank you to my friend Kid Chi for
helping out and until next time see us
space Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]